sans doute 19h à londres d'où antenne 2
réalise en direct journal exceptionnelle
consacrée au sommet des pays
industrialisés non communistes et à
titre d'exemple à la société anglaise
vous y retrouverez le talent et le
visage des journalistes que vous
connaissez qui représente antenne 2 à
l'étranger et qui accompagne aujourd'hui
en quelque sorte leur délégation les
sept carter trudeau giscard d'estaing
schmitt fukuda callaghan et andreotti
ont choisi le cadre historique et
feutrée du 10 downing street tout près
d'ici pour traiter des problèmes
essentiels de notre avenir il représente
un peu plus de la moitié de la
production mondiale ici à londres
pendant trois jours ils s'efforcent de
relancer l'expansion de juguler
l'inflation c'est d'ailleurs plus facile
à dire qu'à faire limiter le chômage qui
touche en gros 15 millions de personnes
dont la moitié en amérique y at il une
solidarité ou bien est-ce chacun pour
soi ce qui ressemblerait un
sauve-qui-peut à cause de la crise qui
les blesse qui s'installent pour
longtemps chez chacun d'eux ils ne
peuvent plus se contenter de gentils
poignée de main ou de propos aimables
comme en 1975 à rambouillet ou en 1976 à
porto rico cette fois jimmy carter les a
rejoint avec le prestige et la
légitimité d'un nouvel élu est aussi
avec son activisme moral les européens
paieront ils la renaissance des états
unis comment seront ils concilier une
réponse commune à cette crise et leur
indépendance pour ceux qui sont souci
c'est ici que cela se joue et c'est
plutôt lors de trail rendez vous que
nous comme l'histoire nous jugerons ce
qu'il parle en notre nom de l'autre côté
du pont au 10 downing street
après quatre heures de discussions
ardues qui ont ouvert ce matin le sommet
de londres et avant le déjeuner officiel
qui était offert à lancaster house les
sept chefs d'état jimmy carter valéry
giscard d'estaing james callaghan helmut
schmidt boulho un maillot dit pierre
trudeau est à quai ou fukuda se sont
promenés à pieds dans l'eau
c'est déjà une indication que
l'atmosphère de ce sommet est détendue
et que les participants sont satisfaits
du début des conversations à l'issue de
la réunion de ce matin tous les pays
sont tombés d'accord pour ceux fixés
trois objectifs assurer la croissance
économique mondiale combattre le chômage
maîtriser l'inflation et puis cet
après-midi première surprise les
participants décidaient de ne rien
modifier ni à leurs objectifs de
croissance économique ni aux moyens de
les atteindre en clair cela signifie
qu'il n'y aura pas de relance global de
relance coordonnés de l'économie
mondiale pourtant l'optimisme ne semble
pas baisser à londres où on se plaît à
souligner que les premiers contacts ont
été marqués par un esprit de franchise
ed coopération qui a permis de jeter de
très bonne base pour la suite des
entretiens
c'est le caractère approfondie des
échanges de vues les européens sont ils
comportés en européens ou en allemand en
anglais en italien français les pays
regardent et courtoise raymond barre
passe la journée à londres le premier à
pouvoir expliquer ce qui s'est passé cet
après midi au cours de la première
conférence il fait en exclusivité pour
antenne 2 je vous en remercie d'ailleurs
monsieur bart
délégation ne pouvait pas ignorer est ni
ce que son pays 2 recevait comme
influences des autres ni l'affluence que
son pays pouvait exercer sur les autres
est ce que vous avez senti ce que le
président a un public disait l'autre
jour soit l autre jour la faiblesse
politique de la plupart des pays
européens non non la discussion
d'ailleurs était une discussion entre
hommes responsables et la faiblesse
politique est quelque chose qui n'a pas
n'a pas été apparente parce que les
gouvernements qui sont là ont la
responsabilité de traiter les problèmes
et il faut que ce problème soit traité
est ce qu'il ya une chance cas pas cette
conférence on voit à long terme se
réduire un peu le chômage dans nos
sociétés écoutez ce matin nous avons
longuement discuté de ce problème et ce
qui était très significatif c'est que
tous les pays ont considéré avec gravité
le problème du chômage est à peu près
dans tous les pays la situation est la
même est-ce qui a des chances dans son
devoir d'aider des lueurs ou des
lumières nous avons constaté ce matin
qu'il ne fallait voir la vie ni en rose
ni en gris mais la voir de façon lucide
pays doivent sanguin
sur une voie qui est celle de l'effort
car nous ne résoudrons pas les problèmes
rapidement quels que soient les régimes
politiques quelles que soient les
régimes politiques et pour longtemps et
pour longtemps si nous savons pratiques
et l'effort pendant le temps nécessaire
si nous savons respecter un certain
nombre de disciplines nous pourrons tous
ensemble retrouver la voie du
développement économique et résoudre
progressivement les problèmes du chômage
comment
vous trouvez jimmy carter le président
carter est un homme simple directe qui
sait écouter qui expose son point de vue
avec une grande modération et avec le
souci de recevoir les suggestions des
origines cherche
je n'ai pas eu cette impression pendant
la journée monsieur bart la dernière
question pour réussir pour réussir ce
que vous avez entrepris à paris vous
avez besoin de vous y consacrer sans
doute est ce que ça veut dire aussi que
de laisser les problèmes politiques
mains de la majorité a d'autres que vous
éblouir les deux et bien écoutez je
crois que ceux qui parlent de
distinction entre l'économie et la
politique
aurais-tu intérêt à voir comment s'était
déroulée la discussion de ce matin et
celle de cet après midi car nous y avons
parlé de problèmes économiques
l'inflation
l'évolution des échanges la nécessité
d'éviter le protectionnisme la nécessité
d'organiser les échanges la nécessité
d'adopter des programmes spécifiques sur
le chômage tout cela nous l'avons fait
parce que nous étions entre hommes qui
avaient la responsabilité de la
politique de leur pays et voyez-vous ce
qui était clair c'est que l'économique
ne sépare pas du social le social ne se
sépare pas de la politique tout cela est
un ensemble et il n'y a plus il n'est
pas possible de
distinguer entre les divers aspects une
action qui doit être globale et continue
en tout cas je remercie premier ministre
est resté avec nous pour cette
conversation en exclusivité que nous
venons de réaliser vous l'avez entendu
probablement les sept ont donc parlé des
problèmes de l'énergie que la plupart
des pays occidentaux sont obligés
d'acheter généralement à l'étranger la
majorité mais pas la grande bretagne qui
a trouvé chez elle un certain nombre de
ressources en particulier dans le nord
beaucoup de pétrole cette découverte
sera t elle suffisante pour sauver
l'économie de ce pays voici en tout cas
notre premier reportage et il est signé
l'autre gagnaire
a body un port de pêche sur la mer du
nord
on y vendait le poisson à la criée comme
un saint malo concarneau la pêche était
la seule richesse une pêche difficile
dans une guerre froide et agité avril se
mourait et les écossais et mido
et puis vint le pétrole est large
aujourd'hui à body n'explose la
population a pratiquement doublé en dix
ans le port ne sent plus le poisson mais
les produits chimiques le mazout
contaminent la mer le gaz l'air mais il
n'ya plus de chômeurs et les pêcheurs
médusées regardent l'histoire
s'accélérer dans une ambiance de
pionniers à la conquête de l'or
parmi eux un français un ch'timi en
écosse depuis 33 ans il ya beaucoup à
changer il
macha le plus terrain est plus une
maison tout ça c'est ses partisans mais
autrement
ça change et ça c'est beaucoup oui et si
on le voit ici peut pas avoir
ils sont partis travailler 21 travailler
dans le pétrole pompé trons
les marins aujourd'hui travaillent sur
les plateformes ou dans les usines et
les chalutiers rouille au milieu des
bateaux flambant neuf aux couleurs de
bonbons des compagnies pétrolières
l'aventuré a commencé il ya quinze ans
avec la prospection les premières
gouttes de pétrole en coulé il ya à
peine deux ans la grande bretagne
aujourd'hui extrait le quart de sa
consommation en 1980 le total elle sera
autosuffisant pendant trente ans il ne
dépensera plus son argent pour acheter
de l'énergie à l'étranger
en 1981 elle sera une des dix grandes
puissances pétrolières du monde elle
rêve à une monnaie redevenu forte et un
nouveau niveau de vie le pétrole va t'il
sauvé la grande bretagne ce n'est pas
sur la difficulté de prospection en a
fait le pétrole le plus cher du monde
pour être rentable il faut que les cours
mondiaux se maintiennent et puis pour
prospecter il a fallu emprunter il faut
aujourd'hui rembourser les emprunts
payer les intérêts et pour maintenir la
production faire de nouveaux
investissements
le restera peu d'argent pour les
britanniques
bien sur l'exploitation pétrolière à
fouetter l'économie soixante mille
emplois ont été créés et si le chômage
augmentait de 100 % dans certaines
régions d'angleterre il n'augmentait que
de 30% en écosse à à petit il n'y a pas
un chômeur mais précisément la majeure
partie du pétrole britannique et au
large des côtes écossaises et les
nationalistes voit dans cette richesse
inattendue de nouvelles raisons d'être
indépendant alors on pourrait imaginer
et c'est bien possible que les causes du
viennent avec ses revenus du pétrole un
tout petit pays riche comme les couettes
ou au moins riches comme norvège parce
que les caciques tout petit p 5 millions
d'habitants tandis qu'un au revers 4 ou
5 millions environ la même chose environ
la même quantité de pétrole mais ça
signifie que le cos alors ce serait un
pays indépendant
pas forcément parce que on pourrait
avoir un pays autonome avec les north a
assemblé nationale reste sous parlement
qui aurait en même temps des revenus de
petro pour le secteur et kroos et la mer
du nord est comme ça on pourrait faire
beaucoup de choses ses revenus par
decosse
en réalité 15% seulement des écossais ne
souhaite pas de changement dans leurs
relations avec la grande-bretagne une
majorité en revanche se prononcent si ce
n'est pour l'indépendance au moins pour
un pouvoir économique la possibilité de
recevoir une partie des revenus du
pétrole et de l'utiliser librement
londres refuse l'angleterre est
largement hypothéquée et le pétrole lui
sert de garantie un journaliste anglais
écrivait il y à peu
quelle ironie du sort si le pétrole de
la mer du nord dont on espérait qu'ils
seraient la planche de salut cause est
en fin de compte l'éclatement de la
grande bretagne
nous reviendrons dans quelques instants
sur tous ces problèmes il ya juste un
hélicoptère qui passe au dessus de moi
ils assurent la sécurité parce que la
plupart des délégations dont se
retrouver dans quelques instants chez la
reine elizabeth au buckingham palace
pour dîner en attendant vous voyez que
la nuit n'est pas encore tombée il fait
froid il ya beaucoup de vent il est
difficile de le faire de l'élégance de
rester coi fait mais vous allez nous
dire maintenant aux gérard holtz qu'elle
est aujourd'hui en france l'actualité pu
nous retrouverons
merci jean pierre bonsoir mon tour
l'essentiel donc de l'actualité en
france pour ce samedi 7 mai c'est avant
tout la réunion du comité directeur du
parti socialiste la dernière rencontre
des dirigeants du ps avant le congrès
national de nantes qui se déroulera à la
mi juin au centre des débats de ce
comité directeur avant tout la recherche
d'un compromis politique entre françois
mitterrand soutenu par la majorité du
parti et le crs qui avait que 25 % des
militants socialistes de représente bien
sûr que la minorité du parti
pour françois mitterrand la perspective
d'une victoire de la gauche aux
prochaines élections législatives impose
que le parti socialiste soit homogène
pour être fort par la voix de même de
claude estier qui vient d'apprendre on
vient d'apprendre il ya quelques minutes
qu'aucun accord n'avait été trouvé
direction du parti poser une question
préalable en quelque sorte qui touche au
fonctionnement interne du parti et qui
est celle de savoir si la minorité doit
continuer à se comporter en organisation
quasiment séparer du parti ayant ses
propres comportements externe et donc
ayant une activité fractionnistes
c'était en quelque sorte une question
préalable et comme il n'a pas été
répondu à cette question préalable bien
le comité directeur a dû constater
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas de synthèse
aujourd'hui à dix mois des élections est
ce qu'en fait ce n'est pas un accord
tactique que vous recherchez alors qu'il
ya des divergences profondes entre les
deux tendances il n'y a pas de
divergences profondes entre les deux
tendances et je voudrais dire que
l'unité du parti n'est pas en cause
depuis 1975 depuis le congrès de pau le
parti socialiste vit avec une majorité
et une minorité et cela n'a pas empêché
le parti socialiste de devenir pendant
cette période le premier parti de france
mais il y a des règles de fonctionnement
du parti alors ces règles alain à
l'heure actuelle ne nous paraissent pas
observé c'est pourquoi nous avons posé
cette question préalable si la réponse
dans le courant de la discussion qui va
se poursuivre d'ici le congrès de nantes
fixée au 17 juin si la réponse de la
minorité nous paraît satisfaisante quant
au fonctionnement interne du parti et
quant à sa décision de ne plus être une
organisation fractionnistes eh bien je
crois qu'à synthèse sera possible parce
qu'il n'y a pas de divergences profondes
sur les problèmes politiques
du côté de la majorité maintenant
olivier stirn qui a quitté le rpr pour
créer le mouvement des sociaux libéraux
vient d'annoncer qu'un comité de liaison
de la majorité sera mis sur pied avant
la fin du mois quelque peu en
contradiction avec les déclarations de
jacques chirac hier soir à montbéliard
olivier stirn a indiqué que c'est le
premier ministre qui devait être
l'animateur est le coordinateur de la
majorité secrétaire d'état aux dom tom
les départements et territoires
d'outre-mer sera avec nous en direct
demain soir sur ce plateau nous
reparlerons avec lui de ses problèmes de
la majorité mais surtout du référendum
sur l'indépendance de djibouti qui a
lieu demain
toujours aucune nouvelle ce soir des six
français enlevés il ya presque une
semaine maintenant par les combattants
du polisario
aujourd'hui robert galley le ministre
français de la coopération s'est rendu à
zohra tu la ville oasis qui était la
cible du raid des soldats sahraoui avant
cela robert galley s'est entretenu dès
son arrivée avec le président mokhtar
ould daddah il a surtout été question
d'une possible
des militaires de la france à la
mauritanie rien n'a encore été décidé
pour l'instant nous avons assez de
soldats il nous faudrait plutôt du
matériel pour résister à l'agression
venus d'algérie ditto à nouakchott car
pour le président ould daddah les choses
sont très claires en ce qui concerne le
rôle d'alger dans cette affaire
c'est la responsabilité de l'algérie qui
est engagée non seulement dans les
attaques qui nous ont qu'une clio sont
faites mais dans l'enlèvement des ces
civils innocents car ce que vous appelez
le polisario n'est que des mercenaires
algériens
réalité par d alger les algériens formés
par les algériens interné par les
algériens a remis par les algériens et
il y a beaucoup de sahraouis algériens
comme il y à déjà alaoui mauritanien la
dent comme il y à des sahraouis
marocains et comme il ya bien sûr des
sahraouis originaires de l'ex sahara
espagnol mais l'ensemble est une armée
de mercenaires
tout à fait algérienne et qui n'aurait
été rien
sans l'algérie de la part de l'algérie
rien ne nous surprend à partir du moment
où elle a érigé un système la piraterie
internationale et la violation des
accords de principe et comme celui d'un
non ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures des autres pays le respect
de l'intégrité territoriale des autres
pays
encore une fois je le répète la part de
l'algérie on ne se surprend qu'attendez
vous maintenant de la france une aide de
militaires financière la sécurité nous
comptons sur nous-mêmes et nous mêmes
pour la série on ne demandons pas à
d'autres d'assurer notre sécurité à
notre place maintenant
ined militaire une en développement de
la coopération militaire est possible si
la partie française
veut l'admettre un télégramme encore de
l'étranger à retenir la mort de xavier
de bourbon parme à l'âge de 88 ans le
prétendant carliste au trône d'espagne
est décédé ce matin d'une crise
cardiaque dans un hôpital en suisse en
sport en tennis la france vient de se
qualifier pour les demi finales de la
zone européenne de la coupe davis en
gagnant cet après-midi le double contre
la pologne victoire de geoffrey
dominguez en cinq sets en football je
vous rappelle qu'il ya ce soir une
journée complète du championnat de
france de première division de mots de
la météo encore le beau temps va quelque
peu se gâcher après de belles éclaircies
le matin les nuages et la pluie vont
revenir sur la moitié nord de la
bretagne à la flandre jusqu'au bassin
parisien dans le sud plutôt du soleil
c'est tout ce que je vous souhaite jean
pierre elkabbach et l'équipe d'antenne 2
à londres du soleil pour la fin de votre
week-end made in britain non comme back
in london
voilà retour à londres ce soir à
l'occasion de ce journal en direct il
est une heure de moins ici qu'à qu'à
paris elle garde toujours ce charme fou
fou fou la société anglaise elle fait
face avec beaucoup de dignité ou
difficultés exceptionnelles qu elle
ressemble à sa vie de tous les jours
dans sa vie quotidienne elle reste
peut-être parfois figé jusqu'à l'ennui
dans ses traditions mais elle sait aussi
claude gagnaire s'adapter passe en
quelque sorte de la compétition à la
concurrence at his forme de solidarité
que l'on trouve ici comme un exemple
mais qui ne va pas jusque là l'égalité
sociale oui ce qui est amusant c'est de
constater que quelqu'un faisait
remarquer un jour qu'on ne savait pas si
c'était l'angleterre qui avait déteint
sur l'inde ou lan sur l'angleterre et
c'est peut-être bien l'angleterre qui
avait des plaintes sur l'inde il n'y a
pas en angleterre réellement de lutte de
classe il ya une sorte de caste et à
l'intérieur de ces castes on n'a pas
l'impression que les personnes
concernées cherche à changer de classe
ou cherchent à passer à une autre classe
et c'est une peu une société figée qui
s'ennuient nom qui sent du non je ne
pense pas qu'il ressent les difficultés
avec un certain trouble un certain
souffle alors c'est la question je ne
suis en angleterre que depuis un mois
mais je suis venu souvent et je me suis
toujours demandé jusqu'à quand les
anglais allait-il accepté se serrer la
ceinture et à partir de quel moment il y
aurait cette espèce de deslandes
renouveau qui les ferait sortir cette
situation il n'y a pas encore de réponse
à cette question on ne sait pas à partir
de quand les anglais trouveront que ça
suffit d'écouter le meilleur exemple
qu'il faut aller le chercher dans le
concret c'est-à-dire non dans une
famille en passant plusieurs jours avec
ce couple et ses enfants daniel bilalian
a pu constater l'évolution du niveau de
vie du mode de vie des anglais à
l'intérieur même d'une famille
la famille colquhoun marque 10 ans
charles 8 ans leur mère eliane d'origine
française sans profession épouse de
robert professeur qui forment des
enseignants dans une école normale de
long
robert peu le coup n'est vraiment ce que
l'on peut appeler un anglais moyen son
salaire 500 livres par mois c'est à dire
environ 4400 francs bruts mais en fait
il ne lui reste que 3200 francs car en
plus d utilisation habituelle on lui
prélève automatiquement sans livres soit
880 francs par mois pour ses impôts cela
représente plus de 10 mille francs par
an au moins quatre fois plus que ce que
paierait un salarié français dans la
même situation
de plus il faut savoir qu'en grande
bretagne les salaires sont pratiquement
bloqué depuis maintenant deux ans
je crois que il y à quelque chose dont
le caractère anglais qui dans un sens
accepte ça et pendant les deux premières
années avec une grande campagne du
gouvernement et avec l'appui des
syndicats on a accepté un blocage des
salaires mais on sent nettement
maintenant que en ce moment où le
gouvernement essaye d'inaugurer une
troisième année de ce qu'on appelle
contrat social il y a des gens qui
quiros bertin ont dit que justement ce
sont les classes moyennes comme la vôtre
comme ceux des professeurs les cadres
moyens
qui sont les plus mécontents de la
situation actuelle parce que l a amené
une sorte d'écrasement des salaires
est-ce que c'est exact oui ça c'est ça
c'est vrai et c'est surtout dû je crois
à au fait qu
avec la l'augmentation uniforme pour
tout le monde depuis deux ans comme je
disais les gens salariés des salaires
moyens trouve qu'ils ont été
défavorisées
si les salaires ne progressent guère les
prix ne vont par contre bon train plus
de 16% 76 et cela bien que de nombreux
produits soient subventionnées ce qui a
le plus augmenté les tarifs publics gaz
électricité transports entre 10 et 20%
vient ensuite l'alimentation et en
premier lieu la viande en train de
devenir comme beaucoup d'autres produits
une véritable denrée de luxe pour les
autres
les choses fraîches par exemple comme
des fruits dont ils ne mangent pas
énormément mais en mangeant moins
durablement par le passé et puis il y a
aussi tout ce qui est les salades et
devient tout et les légumes frais
devient absolument inabordable la
nourriture ne joue pas nos si grand rôle
pour les anglais
ils se nourrissent
mais est-ce que parmi les ménagères
parmi vos amis est ce que vous entendez
des gens vraiment acquis ces
augmentations ont posé des problèmes à
tel point qu'ils devraient obliger de se
résoudre à supprimer les choses où
j'étais trop long les anglais ça se
contenter se débrouille avec et je ne
crois pas qui il ne râle pas alors
je n'ai pas
il souffre peut-être mais il ne le
montre pas
cette apparente résignation peut avoir
trois raisons la première depuis 1945
les anglais ont pris l'habitude de vivre
plus difficilement que les autres
européens deuxième raison le
gouvernement travailliste est encore
soutenu par les syndicats et bon nombre
de salariés
enfin le plus important c'est peut-être
que pour un anglais ce qui compte avant
tout plus que l'argent c'est la qualité
de la vie pendant les loisirs mais aussi
d'autres
il n'y a pas de doute que je crois que
les anglais sont beaucoup moins
matérialiste que par exemple les
français tels que je les vois quand je
vais à paris par exemple je crois que
les anglais sont moins exigeants et il
ya à mon avis ils sont sûrement plus
paresseux que les français mais il ya
bien sûr le gouvernement de temps en
temps faire campagne pour faire campagne
pour qu'on travaille plus
est ce que les anglais réagissent moi je
ne crois pas et lorsque vous lisez par
exemple vous entendez dans la presse
française ou du continent en général
européenne parler de l'angleterre au
bord de la faillite
le ter peau quelle réaction ça vous
inspire c'est à dire quand on va à paris
on ne peut souvent cette question est ce
que l'angleterre est dans une telle ou
telle qu'un critique
il faut qu'il faut répondre en effet qu
on ne le sent pas ici et moi je n'ai pas
l'impression qu'on est sur le board d'un
catastrophe n'ont finalement les god
save the queen et par la même occasion
le royaume c'est ce que sans doute pense
encore la majorité de l'angleterre
l'angleterre qui au moment où les
grandes nations industrialisées cherche
un nouvel art de vivre présente
l'expérience d'un pays conduits par la
force des choses par nature mais aussi
par volonté politique vers une société
plus égalitaire où l'argent est l'effort
ne seraient plus les seules valeurs une
société parfaitement adapté à une
croissance économique mondiale ralentit
dit ses partisans une société décadente
affirment ses adversaires
un autour de faire en quelque sorte un
petit sommet avec tous les
correspondants d'antenne 2
les pays du monde que me suivant mais
d'abord claude gagnaire la famille que
nous venons de voir la famille anglaise
comment peut-elle réagir à cette
conférence avec indifférence et humour
peut-être avec humour peut-être cette
famille en particulier je ne sais pas le
sentiment général du britannique et qu'
ils attendent cette combi cette
conférence une confirmation d excellents
rapports qu'il ya entre les etats-unis
et la grande-bretagne
car les anglais ne sont pas tout à fait
très très chaud pour cette europe et il
compte beaucoup plus sur l'oncle sam
pour les sortir de la situation
difficile qu'ils sont en train de
traverser pour que l'amérique relance en
économie accepte d'importer des produits
britanniques et soutien de la
grande-bretagne alors samse jimmy carter
comment jacques séguin
à bord team cette conférence vous l'avez
suivi vous étiez avec lui tous ces jours
ci je crois que à l'issue de la première
journée on peut dire que carter alors sa
conférence avec l'intention de ne pas
trop faire de peine à ses alliés
européens mais surtout avec l'intention
après avoir marqué de nombreux points
aux états unis avec l'intention de
s'imposer comme leader du monde
occidental il l'a montré hier dans le
nord de l'angleterre en faisant une
nouvelle campagne électorale est un
territoire monsieur partys et qu'il
était simple ouvert qu'il acceptait de
ne pas imposer enfin il présente la
meilleure phase de lune ne pas céder sur
l'essentiel et ne pas brusquer les
partenaires et dans la mesure où quand
au niveau de vie américain il a remué la
mairie si vous savez qu'avec son plan
énergétique il habite il faut laisse ben
better 1 et ça veut bon c'est laid c'est
une bêta ça veut dire plus petit c'est
bien meilleur et maintenant on pense
notamment aux grosses voitures va-t-on
vivre dans des petites voitures il ya un
aspect moral il y a un aspect de
domination chez kartell ne faut pas se
laisser prendre uniquement à son à son
sourire je ne sais pas si importante
pour lui ce qui est absolument c'est sa
première sortie hors des états unis et
apparemment si l'on en juge aux
réactions des différents européen il a
marqué des points mais peut être plus
sur le plan politique car au plan
économique il faut attendre je retiens
que l'american way of life devrait en
prendre un coup lorsque les mesures de
carter sont appliquées sur l'énergie
présente dans 10 ans on attendra 6100
les américains répondent ils commencent
à peut-être plus tôt et alors en italie
victor vraiment en italie on l'a on veut
avoir un sujet sur une famille
britannique il faut dire qu'en ce moment
les familles
problème le niveau de vie a nettement
baissé à 2 puis ils ont trois ans depuis
la crise du pétrole cela dit comme les
italiens continuent de vivre au dessus
de leurs moyens ne sais pas c'est
peut-être dans leur tempérament alors ce
qui provoque une inflation tout de même
de 21% les chiffre fatidique
et puis à l'état aussi qui montre
l'exemple en empruntant à l'étranger
l'italie actuellement une dette de 35
milliards de francs il ya les
municipalités qui empruntent pour
rembourser l'argent qui avait été
emprunté avant alors l'un dans l'autre
il ya une espèce de bouillonnement en
même temps dans l'inflation et puis ya
aussi ce chômage il ya quand même six
pour cent de la population qui est au
chômage
voilà ce site un peu ça enfin la
régulation avec des implications
politiques et des conséquences
politiques l'instabilité et puis ce que
l'on sait tous les jours à travers les
reportages que vous en voyez c'est ça
oui alors comment redresser cette
situation économique que les communistes
demandent de participer à la gestion du
pays d'entrée même dans le gouvernement
pour appliquer certaines mesures encore
d'austérité quoique le gouvernement
d'haïti en a déjà triste râler comme
lists août à la porte la du gouvernement
pour prendre des mesures pour l'économie
pour michel meyer de bonnes lorsque vous
entendez parler d'instabilité
certains troubles que nous vivons à la
fois sociaux et politiques un peu
partout vous regardez s'entend presque
allemand avec la lune aux stands à
l'aigle à la limite les allemands sont
beaucoup plus inquiet pour les français
disent adieu pour eux mêmes parce qu'ils
vont plutôt moins mal que leurs voisins
européens cela plusieurs raisons
rapports sociaux et cetera et cetera
mais leur inflation est plutôt faible
leur taux de chômage n'est pas très
élevé malgré tout et leurs chômeurs sont
assez bien soutenu en plus j'ai un
comportement allemand assez particulier
qui est assez différent du comportement
français peut-être il crée généralement
dix minutes avant d'avoir mal et ils
prennent leurs précautions pour ne pas
avoir mal c'est ce qui a caractérisé la
politique allemande notamment c'est pour
et et demi durant les dernières années
en plus les allemands ont parfaitement
conscience canal mort d'un ouvrier
allemand sur quatre travaillent pour
l'exportation dont ils sont en masse
qu'il ya derrière le chancelier qui
essaiera d'obtenir que personne ne
prenne ici de mesures protectionnistes
et monsieur schmitt n'a pas l'air de
trop commode dans ses rapports avec les
américains en ce moment j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'a pas de sens
laisser faire absolument je crois que
pour est une expression un peu ample osé
découvre les délices d'une espèce de
gaullisme germanique dix ans après la
france
et bien maintenant il est temps
peut-être de voir un reportage que nous
avons préparé sur les écossais qui ont
peu d'occasions de se rassembler la
dernière fois qu'ils s'étaient
rassemblés en angleterre cet été chez
eux c'était à l'occasion du coroner de
la reine elizabeth au moment du jubilé
ils en ont profité le viennent de
partout certains étaient absents depuis
des années il en profite regarder dans
quelles conditions
c'était la semaine dernière à edimbourg
capitale historique de l'ecosse
on n'avait jamais vu autant de mcgregor
mcdonald's mcbride et autres macintosh
personnage de légende amateurs de whisky
ou héros de bande dessinée que ce
jour-là ce jour du grand rassemblement
des clans
le deuxième en 25 ans
et
ils en étaient venues de parc d'abord
les états unis le premier est pas le
moine john lindsay ancien maire de new
york tente savait de quoi il était le
plus fier porter la bannière étoilée ou
porter le clip
ils en étaient venus d'australie de
nouvelle zélande afrique du sud du
canada beaucoup découvrent et l'ecosse
pour la première fois
il avait cassé leur tirelire que lançait
pourtant solide pour ce retour aux
sources et pour s'y abreuver
ils en étaient même venus de paris
1 au moins descendant de guerriers venus
perturber l'histoire de france il ya
quelques siècles lui aussi pour un
pèlerinage après 400 ans vous sentez
plus français que l'écossé ou toujours
écossais toujours écossais
mais je ne dis pas que je ne suis pas
français
mais qu'est ce que ça signifie être
écossais
ça signifie à part d'abord
l'appartenance à un clan
cette annonce une enceinte sacré si vous
voulez dans laquelle les gens rentrent
se rattache aux mêmes ancêtres porte les
mêmes couleurs
et se retrouve toujours au faîte au
rouge à l'universel
à l'origine le plan désigner les gens
qui habitaient une même vallée et puis
comme il n'avait pas de nom de famille
ils prirent celui du seigneur de la
vallée en vain comme ils se marièrent
entre eux la population d'une même
valait de vin une grande famille et tout
le monde s'appelait kilpatrick ou mac
kenzie pas de hiérarchie un seul chef le
seigneur et c'est pourquoi les egos et
comprennent mal les différences de glace
qui divise la société anglaise le voisin
pas toujours aimé
ils étaient quelques milliers la semaine
dernière représentant une centaine de
clans
beaucoup venus de l'étranger rappeler
qu'il ya plus d'écossé en des frontières
qu'en écosse mêmes et qu'ils ne veulent
pas oublier
pour le jubilé de la reine elizabeth
bien il accepte tous de s'associer à
l'hommage rendu cette année la
souveraine beaucoup de français l'ont
constaté vont le constater ici à la fin
de l'année puis nous nous font des
reportages la souveraine qui maintient
le cap claude gaignierre l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure il ya une différence
considérable de revenus des inégalités
évidente dans l'est plus pour ont perdu
peut-être l'habitude de se plaindre et
ils se retrouvent en tout cas tous avec
admiration comme aujourd'hui pour voir
défiler les rolls royce du royaume et
des fidèles de sa majesté
même si vous êtes un spécialiste de
l'automobile je suis sûr j'en fais le
pari que vous ne devinerez jamais dans
quel genre et dans quel type de voiture
je suis installé je crois qu'il vaut
mieux que vous donniez tout de suite
votre langue au chat comme on dit et
bien cet engin c'est un engin blindé qui
a été construit vers 1920 était
construite pour l'armée britannique il
est équipé vous le voyez d'une
mitrailleuse qui se trouve à l'avant du
véhicule sa particularité ça n'est pas
d'être un engin blindé il est tout à
fait comme les autres sa particularité
c'est d'être un engin fabriqué par la
firme rolls royce comme quoi il n'ya pas
que des berlines de luxe dans la gamme
des rolls royce
il était à peu près 500 venus participer
à ce véritable woodstock de la rolls
royce arrivée de grande bretagne et
d'ailleurs 500 modèles tous différents
les uns des autres bichonnés jusqu'au
dernier moment pour défiler devant la
reine à l'intérieur de son château de
windsor
vous savez rolls royce a la réputation
d'avoir des voitures très confortable et
bien vous allez le découvrir ici cette
rolls royce est une des capitales qui
date de 1910 mais ce n'est pas n'importe
quel les capitales voyez pour protéger
le pilote et son compagnon il y a une
magnifique glace et puis vous le voyez
en passant derrière les gens qui sont
installés à l'arrière de la berline ont
eux aussi une glace magnifique glace de
protection avec un plaid très
confortable qui protège l'argent voilà
c'est ça le confort rolls royce
cette voiture dans laquelle je suis
assise et la plus ancienne rolls royce
né de l'association entre deux
ingénieurs anglais rôle héroïque cette
voiture date de 1904 c'est le plus
ancien modèle de ce défilé du jubilé de
la reine
après les spécimens les plus rares où
les plus vieux ou encore les plus
extravagants dont le prix est
inestimable façon aux modèles plus
courants j'allais dire plus ordinaire
mais qui suffisent déjà à faire rêver et
maintenant plutôt que de parler
performance contentons nous de les
regarder défiler
la reine offre en ce moment en son
palais de buckingham un grand dîner aux
chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui
participe au sommet nous en parlerons
demain pour parler également des
conversations politiques avec tous les
correspondants antenne 2 est venu ici et
qui sont à l'étranger et aussi paul
nahon et daniel bilalian merci d'avoir
suivi ce journal en direct de londres
goodnight
à